[Music]
foreign
I grew up in La the area is called West
Adams the same gang's always been there
since like the 60s and late 50s you know
the same neighborhood and what gang is
that harpies so like the new generation
came in which was dead end that's my
generation I think like the end of the
80s it just it picked up like gang
violence you know and you know some kids
they don't have no parents but like I
have parents you know but for some
reason that's like your it becomes like
your second family and since you're from
there it almost makes you feel like
you need to be part of that and like
I've been pulled away from it
like in different instances in my life
but I always would make my my way back
to it
can you explain that well like
when I was younger I remember um
my dad had went up north or whatever
like Northern California and um they try
to send me out there you know like to
get us away from it
um next thing you know I'm in a juvenile
hall with it for like almost a year up
north up North and then and then the
minute I'm out
I get a Greyhound ticket back to L.A and
I remember this is the old Greyhound
station right in downtown where it was I
think seventh street is that where it
was at 70. that's what that's where it's
at right now though before it was like
no it was like off of Broadway right
there yeah and it was like a whole like
uh
yeah it was upstairs yeah ghetto as [__]
like grimy as [__] I'm gonna show up
like fresh out of like Juvenile Hall
with like a duffel
with some money in my pocket and like
I'm back in L.A late night little kid on
the taxi even later in my life when I
was gone for all those years I just was
like like long to be in the hood you
know like I I thought I did until I came
back and I was like man [__] changed on
me you know what I didn't I didn't feel
the same to me you know because
well the same faces they're not there no
more there's new faces and
you know it's it's that energy it kind
of like shifted on me a little bit you
know and and when it and when that
happens you got to play catching up but
sometimes when you play that catching up
you're gonna get wrapped up in the in
the catching up you know it's crazy that
you said that you chose to come back you
know because the notion that the world
get is that you forced into that stuff
man you know and like I said myself you
know it was something I chose because of
all the love that I got you know from my
folks there man it was family orientated
and my father wasn't around much you
know and and to just get that love from
you know other homies like that man you
know it's just something you choose to
do man you know do you feel the same way
or you feel different because it was
similar for you right I mean you went
away you went up you you were in uh
Oregon right like you went up and then
you came back I mean what what is that
draw I mean when you're coming back are
you saying I want to be in the
neighborhood I want to get back with the
people and this get like like like like
try to explain that to people who have
no idea you know it's crazy because this
is saying you could take the homie out
the hood but you can't take the hood out
the homeboy and that's how it is man you
know you know your roots man you know
and
you bounce out of town they could take
you to you know because they send me out
of town to stay out of trouble yeah you
know and I went out of town I played
bald I did all that [__] man you know
but
you come back and it ain't like you
choose
to get in trouble man it's just [__]
that's just randomly happens you got so
much love for the people that's around
you you know you you make bad decisions
you know and that's just the way life is
you know
and and that's why one of the things I
say it's not it was never a forced move
you know it's like you chose that love
yeah you know and that's how I feel you
know you know it's that's exactly how it
is you know um
like like now I always be in the hood
like I'm always driving through it I
stop and eat there
you know but it's not more like me you
know I think I'm too old to be like
posted up over there and hanging out
corners it's different now you know
especially like because over there like
my neighborhood got hit with a RICO
indictment so
it changed that [__] it that changed
everything you know I grew up in in
Washington DC it was very it was very
different but
you know there's nothing I wanted to do
more than sort of be with my friends and
we you know we would you know our our
version was just got street fighting you
know like but there was a thing about it
that like it's not that we were like
looking for it but it was a way to kind
of show each other how much we loved
each other yeah is that component there
I think so I think um
or like a gang is like a family
you know and and even in the family
there's like like a real family there's
there's problems but but let's let's say
you don't get along with your brother
but then some other guy comes and beats
up your brother you're about on it
that's right so it's the same like in
the neighborhood it's like you know you
got so many guys like there's little
different groups and subsets and and all
these things but
a situation will happen and it like
brings everybody together so talk about
that talk about like how like can you
give me an example of when you guys were
youngsters were like violence like you
know sort of uh getting each other's
back however you want to look at it but
engaging in some sort of like physical
violence together brought groups of
young men brought you as young men
together
like I'm I'm gonna tell you a situation
but I'm not gonna go into it maybe out
there I'll tell you about it cool but
there was this one time where basically
like it it was the world against us
right and um we're at Hoover Park all my
neighborhood maybe like I mean not all
of it but like the active ones maybe
like 60 70 of us right Hoover Park is on
the corner of Hoover and Adams and we're
in there and um all these trucks and
cars start pulling up on us
a lot of them 20 something like that to
come and get us
and um it like this looked like um that
movie the city of gods when all the
little kids pull their pull their thing
out that's what that's what it was it
was like
30 40 50 guns pointing at them so it was
like oh [__] they just took off because
we was just like we're so United and
then we have different spots in the
neighborhood so that was one of our
Hangouts another one we had was on 39th
in Vermont and back of these apartments
because the homies lived in these
apartments so it's like we're moving as
a unit that deep that many cars like
okay now we're gonna go to this other
spot and then because my neighborhood
was like divided between southwest
police department and Rampart so then
you know now let's go on the rampart
side so we'll go over there on 20th and
Vermont so it gets hot over here we'll
switch over there but we're moving as a
unit like deep it bondage you guys yeah
so and then
on top of that like we had a lot of
murders you know like like let's just
say in in 91 they killed 17 of my homies
in one year
so who who who was coming at you guys
like in L.A nobody gets along with
nobody you know basically it's like
if they inform if they inform your hood
they're your enemies
that's it like
you don't recognize them like get them
that's how that was like the 90s
mentality you know
they ain't one of yours get them is that
was that the same for you guys it is and
is it like slips around you know it's a
survival tactic man you know what I'm
saying you know it but it was just
when you're that young man you are
partying a lot and with all the liquor
and drugs and stuff in people's body you
know stuff can click off it for sure you
know at the snap of a finger so
it's just you know with all the stuff in
the mix of the body man you know it's
it's always a lot of beef chomping off a
lot of problems a lot of situations a
lot you know and then you know everybody
don't agree on the same color
you know everybody don't agree on the
same name the same number whatever the
case may be so you know it was always
War it's always War man you know so you
just got to be on your p's and q's man
you know around she told every time you
walk out the door basically you know
what I'm saying you walk your dog down
the street you better be on your p's and
q's down where you were at did you know
about the Harveys or did you know what
was your take on that I add up you know
harpies was kind of you spread it out
you know and and uh one of my best
buddies named Joe we used to call it
Mexican Joe you know what I'm saying and
I dealt with him for different reasons
you know and he was from harpies him and
all his brothers and everything you know
and we was thick as thieves you know
what I'm saying he grew up around the
east side where I'm at down in the 50s
you know everybody knew Mexican Joe you
know what I'm saying and to this day
everybody no Mexican Joe and his
brothers you know yeah harpies was
around but I knew he definitely knew
about harpies man because those dudes
when they tagged they doing big old
[__] heartbeat letters you know
yeah and how about you did you know
about bow at all did you know about what
I don't know Bo but I knew about like
like when like when um like when you
know you're you're down there growing up
you learn about everything so you know I
go past here it could be like this is
the Florence is or there's the east
coast is or you you start okay the
Hoovers are over here or the South floor
so you start knowing all the gangs like
all the areas so I've been you know I've
been heard about the Pueblo since I was
a little kid but plus my my mama's
comada used to live somewhere over there
and we used to you know like for us like
seeing gang writing
it's like I don't know I just just when
you're young you like seeing that you
know because I used to ride on the walls
a lot so it's like no you you know
that's how you know where you're at too
yeah you pay attention to it man that's
like
you know you know if you need to go
around
no you know or whatever you know what
I'm saying depending on what depending
on what like give me an example of
something for somebody who doesn't know
[__] about it let me example of
something you would see on all the way
I'm a blood man my neighborhood is a
blood if I'm just say getting off the
bus and I see a big old BK on the wall
I ain't gonna walk that direction
because I already know what that means
blood killer so you know I'm gonna try
to figure something else maybe get out a
few stops down and see if I can walk
through somewhere where you know it's a
little more safer you know for me you
know what I'm saying and same thing with
a [__] they see CK on the water nine
times ten they're gonna hesitate your
car break down anything you know what
I'm saying you're trying to get up out
of there you know what I'm saying he
says you already know that's a calling
card and not going but you might not
make it out right straight up right
can you just sort of again like kind of
just like walk me through you know the
90s mentality sort of like how it was
different from girl you know from from
being from being young and or what that
was like
I mean when I was young this before I
was like like in the gang but I grew up
in the gang so I was always like
like it was going to happen anyways I
always felt like I was part of it even
like as a kid and there's this one of my
homies that uh like he's like a legend
where I'm from
and I was looked up to him but he was a
little kid I was younger than him but I
remember him pulling up to the house
crying with a big ass gun some like
dirty hairy [__]
crying asking one of my Bros to take him
on a mission because LAPD has just had
just dropped them off in the enemy
neighborhood
put them there they [__] them up and
he wanted his get back a little kid you
know and I always remember that in my
head the kid the the dudes in the other
neighborhood [__] him up they beat him
up he's like bad they took him right to
where they were like they're spot that
was pretty common thing to do but yeah
yeah yeah
so real commonly talked about that
before and
um so I always have that that in my mind
like I always remember that about him
like he was a little kid but he was
already with the he was on another level
like he was acting like a grown-up on
his mentality like I want my get back
like
and I don't want to fight I want to like
take it to the next level you know I
mean are there times where you you felt
like it was hopeless and it wasn't about
anything or or did that never enter into
your minds I mean for me it was just the
H the hood and that's it like
whether we were wrong right
I don't I don't think that even mattered
because once you know you come into it
you just keep it going you know and and
now that I'm older
you know I see things different I I [__]
with a lot of my enemies like a lot of
my enemies that
that back then there's no way I would be
like talking to him or nothing but now
you know
like my worst enemies you know I'm over
here chopping it up with them inviting
them to like invite them to my shows you
know I have my enemies at my shows and
this and it's cool you know it's like
they grew up too you know so they like
and we're all from the same area we were
all going at it with each other when
we're younger
and now it's like we look at it like
you know because Anything could happen I
get in a car accident down the street
and it's over or whatever plane crash
whatever but we look at it like damn we
made it that [__] was kind of crazy like
we made it out of there and then we both
we both have people that didn't make it
that we loved that's right and or people
that went away that you know that we
love and
so we all go through the same thing so
we get it like at the end like now it's
like
it's just like mutual respect and and
there's sort of like there's some love
right there you know even though we
enemies and everything is cool you know
tell us a little bit about just kind of
what got you out of what got you out of
who just your area and okay well like
I'm gonna say like 2001 2002
around that time there was a situation I
went to this to this place where a young
man lost his life
and and you know like
my name just came up you know and and
next thing you know is like
the [__] like you know how it is in the
hood like if someone will plant a scene
in the [__] snowballs next thing you
know I'm on um Ellie's Most Wanted
so you were at you you were at somewhat
like some party or something like that
and and someone got killed
you know situation took place the young
man lost his life and now my name's in
the mix so now
you know get them
so me I kind of like backed away and and
and you know you sometimes when these
things happen you need you need time to
think how old were you then I was like I
don't know if I was like 25 26 I was you
know and had you been locked up before
yeah I've been I had you know since I
was young you know I'm going to juvenile
Halls 2018 I started going to County
then I went to prison before
some like robberies and then um but I
have been out for for a while because
you know I was did music and was always
I mean I work
sell dope I just like you know it was
just little a mix of everything you know
be in the neighborhood so
it was like one foot in like one foot in
one foot out type and then this happens
and I decided to leave I'm like nah I
just I I need to like clear my mind and
because a lot of things go through your
mind when especially like the way it
happened to me they got this guy now
they got this guy oh [__] they're
they're going down the line so so I
ended up in Mexico so so when you make
that decision yeah basically these you
know that they're coming after you for
murder yeah and everybody yeah can you
explain the psychology of it I mean it
[__] with you but just because I know a
lot of people that that had got life
already like crazy sentences whether it
be 80 nights alive
you know even seven alive you know
people got seven life been in their 30
years right you know when you're out
there you don't care but when you you
now you got to deal with it you care
like it's like you wake up and then and
it's it's like the real world you know
and then um
so you know I left and and I get over
there and um
my life was so fast and once I crossed
over my life started going slow and I
said Mexico right yeah it just went slow
like I know on my end I didn't seen
people get charged with murders they
never did nothing they never were around
right had nothing to do with right and
went and got life sentence for murders
that they didn't do you know and and I'm
sure like you know that's one of the
thoughts that probably went through your
head huh like yeah I'm in a lose-lose
situation yep and then you know it's on
the TV it just made it look like oh man
this [__] looks bad you know and um I
remember I had a they have your face on
the teeth yeah yeah I had a VHS copy of
that [__] and I watched that [__] like
like three or four hours at a time over
I rewind it and try to like break up
every little word that was said to try
to like
that was I always was working on my case
by doing that you know like okay this
news reporter guy's saying this this and
this [__] line
[__] what is the actual like when
you're in that situation are you are you
hiding I mean you're not at home right I
mean like before you go to Mexico you're
seeing that on the TV I seen it when I
was in Mexico when you were in Mexico
yeah when I took off I just took off
once I get to Mexico I get that someone
sends that to me and I have it and it's
just I remember the day that it came out
in the news I was in this in this house
um
that was that was like the hiding spot
or whatever that's where we're at
and then I had put a phone in this house
but I I was upstairs so the phone was
ringing all night like well it was
nighttime it was ringing and ringing I'm
like no one has this well like like two
or three people at the number like who
the [__] is calling and you know this
Mexico is like scary [__] haunted
Housewives and [__] like I'm going down
there type [__] so then um you know like
this [__] is dark and you know you hear
[__] roosters and pigs making noises
so over there you know it's like oh it's
like folk stories and [__] you know the
devil you might that put my pop out on
you or whatever you know and um so
finally I go down
and then I I'm like what's up man fool
you just came out on the news
and and what they say are for it's all
bad the person on the other side is
[__] scaring me and [__] like man
this this and that they said this this
and that they had your picture they had
the homies picture and they're saying
like
um so that next day
I remember um
it was crazy because in that town my
uncle was like running for office right
in that town in Mexico in that town
that's why you went there I just went
there because where else I'm gonna go
right you know and
um
so I like and they won
they won right so it's a big celebration
there's parades and all this [__] and
and the News hit me and it was hot it
was a sunny day and like my when my my
house was at it was like down the street
from downtown so I'm walking up towards
downtown busy as [__] I'm just like I'm
out of it it's in my head
and I'm just I'm feeling like it's just
closing in on me but this is like in
year one or less than Year One
I'm like nauseous I go in the little
store buy a little bucket of beer these
little tiny beers like this and I like
pound like six of them like just to feel
a little bit calm and I'm just like in
the cut and I'm like paranoid I've been
paranoid I was paranoid What
specifically are you paranoid about the
the government coming after me like like
I'm thinking so there's not like you're
not safe down there nah cause they got
me down there in the end they got me
down there and um so
you know I ended up making my way to my
uncle's house the celebration
everybody's happy
and then um I tell I'm right I told my
Uncle I'm like man I came on the news
yesterday and he's like who gives a [__]
forget about that [__] here's another
beer eat and I'm eating and everything
and I was dying to call the U.S that
night because I it was just like I
wanted to hear somebody else's opinion
so I did I waited till like I went to a
uh a pay phone over there you would buy
these like little um like a little card
like a little credit card and you could
put like you know 50 pesos 100 pesos on
it like five bucks ten bucks whatever
and then I went to this pay form and I
called this person right and they're
like they like they're like yeah shit's
bad and I'm like oh man
and by this time I'm like kind of like
drunk and I'm just like sad I'm just
like oh man but you know like it it
would come in waves
I would snap out of it I'll get involved
in some other [__] up you know but then
like things will remind me of it like
all the time you know and man you're a
fugitive
did the people in Mexico that you were
dealing with your family or whoever did
they know that you were a fugitive they
started knowing you know because they
basically in in in Mexico is like this
when they see a uh like a
Mexican-American over there or or just
like me
either he's deported or he's a fugitive
if he's there longer than a month after
a month they're like what the [__] is
this dude don't still doing here like
you know people from the U.S only go for
a little bit and visit the family you
know my family every year would travel
like
10 15 cars with Caravan all the way to
Jalisco to stay where my family's from
and um at a certain time of the years
they have these like festivals right
there and my whole family will go to
this Festival every year but when that
fist it's a wrap everybody you see all
your passes back back to the U.S so I'm
still there
and I'm walking
you know you come from the US you got to
be driving some trucks some [__] I'm
over here walking around there I'm I'm
starting to stand out people are
starting to notice me you know and um my
boy that I that that we both went down
there
we split up when we're like man we got
to split up because together we're more
obvious wanted to yeah yeah he was he
was my co-defendant
so then um
you know we split up and then
you know what I'm telling you my life
got slow which was cool in a way like
it's like soul-searching happen
I didn't like it but then I started
liking it you know like my you know you
start finding things about the family
like history like
you know things that you don't care
about I didn't care about none of that
in La you know
nothing it's not important I just like
going to Mexico when I was a kid because
we're like fireworks
smoke weed it was over here [__]
eating McDonald's every day in the U.S
and [__] like that you know anything I
for Figaroa right there by USC they'll
Taco Taco Bell it's garbage it's garbage
and [__] and then I go with it I start
eating like home cooked home soon like
vegetables and like you know beef and
chicken and I'll start eating right and
I don't know [__] just starts changing
for me you know
and um I I was already training martial
arts before I went with Dave and all of
them before I left oh is that right yeah
I was already trained with mosquito with
Richard yeah yeah I think I made a blue
belt with him before I went and it's
crazy when I went on the run all I took
was a ghee wow again a cup you know some
clothes but I took that ghee and then
right there where I was at they had a
Kenpo School
so I pull up one day and I'm like hey
what's up do I get two free classes yeah
karate schools give me two free classes
and then you got to start paying they're
like yeah come through but you got to
spar them all the dudes let's go I'm
like all right cool so then um you know
I just start training with them and
that's what I'm saying like my life was
kind of slow I started liking it like
yeah and then um
I get a call from my boy one day and
he's I'll pack up there's work there's
[__] to do now
I'm I'm coming through like in four or
five hours this is your co-defendant yep
and then he picks me up
we we go to this we go to this uh Studio
Usman which is also Jalisco
this is the mission
and I was like oh man so now you got
that work that you heard yeah so I'm
like I'm like oh like that see in the
beginning like where my family's from it
it never was like well I didn't see it
like like cartel that whole cartel thing
wasn't there but it was coming in
and then um little by little I started
seeing like oh [__] this shit's like
something another level on him you know
can you explain to me things that you
saw that made you see that it was on
another level or that it was coming like
I'm gonna give you an example
um I was I was over there one time right
see my uncle had this um when you shoot
pool
and then he had all these businesses in
this town he had a star video games so I
would always be over there and then like
on one of the days they would um they
would uh shut like they would just make
one street of [__] swap meet in the
middle of the street long ass street is
a [__] outdoor swap meet so I go over
there you know buy zig zags buy some
bootleg movies
you know look at people because I'll be
inside you know like most of the time I
was in unless I had to go somewhere and
then um just to breathe you know be
around people and then
so this dude
there was this little like little like
it's like Europe where they have those
little circle things you go around as
you're driving so they have those
everywhere in Mexico so right in front
of my my uncle's house and the stores
and this pool my two cousins were
sitting there and this dude
bald-headed dude like you know gang
member
pass by in a beach cruiser Mad Dogging
them scaring them
so you know I call out to him you know
and I'm still on like kind of
elementality I'm like I throw the Hat on
when he passed by he turns around looks
at me I'm like hard piece he goes
so that was it a week later I'm like man
I'm gonna go back over there like my
that mentality man bang on this fool let
me find them let me run into them so it
took about two weeks I ran into this
fool my cousin was sitting on that bench
again this food's like grilling them
scaring them you know
and I told them hey where the [__] you
from and he and then he goes I'm from
this place and I'm like are you that he
goes no
then what are you and then you know he
gave me some stupid response like well
this West Side heart piece you know
whatever even though you're in Mexico
yeah I'm in Mexico he leaves
and then I'm chilling right there with
my two cousins I'm like man you fools
are scary man people shouldn't chew you
fools could jump this fool [__] that
phone
and um while I'm there all of a sudden I
like it's like a little Hill that leaves
that little thing
I see dudes like coming running like
zigzagging in between cars I'm like what
the [__]
those coming up with like sticks old
ugly ass shotgun um like all these like
some Warriors type [__] like the movie
Warriors like a dude with a chain some
[__] with you know like a stick with
Nails in it like all kinds of like
makeshift weapons right tiger on a leash
and [__] yeah and and they come and they
surround me right
and then like the like the main dude
right he like he got a big gun and and
and then like the dude that was on the
bike he's trying to see we want to
Sucker Punch me so he's like to my left
but the dude over here with the gun with
the handgun
so I'm like okay this is the dude so I'm
like hey look I don't have a problem
with none of y'all I have a problem with
him and I called them out
can I just get down with them right now
and fix it because I don't have I kept
on telling them like over and over like
I don't got a problem
with any of y'all you know so so they
were like oh [__] this food's like he's
being sincere yeah you're showing hard
and and plus I was like you know it was
a dangerous situation you know
and then on my cousins his grandfather
comes out with like a 357 and they my
family calls me Pelon so he's like
belong get inside and he kicks everybody
out
kicks everybody out right so then
whatever more [__] happened but later
down the line the line
I not start moving around I'm in
different states now I'm like in Baja
like in TJ I'm moving around
and I kept training right so one day
they called me and they're like okay
it's time for you to come down do your
black belt test it's weird how this [__]
happened
so I'm like I call my cousins the same
two and I'm like hey to my uncle because
he had these big Honda motorcycles these
quads tell them if I could get one so I
could move around in it and then go to
the spot and buy me a bag of weed I'm
gonna give you the money when I get over
there
and then and then pick me up this day
from the airport so they picked me up
from the airport where's my weed at no I
don't got it
so
we go to the spot where they sell the
weed
and the dude that was in there when I
left before he was straight when I come
back which is like seven eight months
nine months later she's [__] tweaked
out oh man
I'm in I'm in the little trap spot he's
in there smoking and this is like before
I don't think they even have pookies in
in Mexico they're smoking on a [__]
light bulb you know and I come in there
and I you know I'm I'm a jokester I like
clowning and all that [__] and he's like
why are you down here and I'm like can
you do a hit I'm just [__] with him
and this Fool's like what I'm like yeah
I'm just gonna do it I'm gonna get on
he's like oh [__]
so that was that was it I forgot about
this dude when I was there about a week
you know I did my little my black belt
test got my [__] happy that's why I'm
gonna call Richard I call Richard I
drank these two they're like 40 ounces
of kokawamas I went when I got that test
I went and bought two I just pounded
them and I caught Richard and I'm like
hey bro I just got my [__] black belt
what so then I leave I fly out right
so then a month later or two months
maybe two months later you know I don't
know that same dude that bald-headed
dude that was punking my cousins
he um he uh they found him on the side
of the river they emptied they hit him
with two AKs empty both a case on them
and and shot him in the face like a
whole clip in his face too with a
handgun
and I was and my cousins tell me that
right then they're like hey you know
that one dude it's a rap they found him
by the river
you know he's full of hoes so I was like
all right that's cool [__] him you know
it was [__] negative ass Vibes
anyways you know what dude was starting
trouble and he goes yeah but the bad
thing they're saying you did it I was
like oh man what the [__] I'm like I
I've been gone like two months like
there's no way I could have been I'm
over here in the Border you know like
got nothing to do with that [__] yeah
man but remember that tweak that fool
yeah so he's like you know that tweaked
out fool like you know how their mind
works they gluing [__] together wow
masterminding [__] in their own like
they're like it's like they're psychotic
you know but what I'm saying is that
like that dude Mexico was different you
can't be hard in Mexico you you out
there walking around [__] giving
people dirty looks you're not gonna get
nowhere I don't care if you just
like you just did 30 years in prison in
the U.S
if you intimidate somebody in Mexico
um mysteriously some [__] will happen to
you I started seeing more things like
this that's when I I knew like yeah it's
a different ball game over here and how
did that make you feel that it was a
different ball game
no well after like I had to um I had to
catch up to it and be like not that you
know I just have to be on the same page
with it they put you in another criminal
situation you already got your
bachelor's
you know you already you got your
Associates you got your bachelor's and
you probably did some internship along
the way you know so just adjust the new
rules yeah you just you just adjust
that's that's basically what happened I
just had like not only me because
there's a lot of people that were just
like me over there and they had to
adjust whether they were deported or
fugitives like they had to like mind
somebody I mean it's just like
mysterious should be happening over
there like that's what I'm saying like
just a dirty look could be enough you
know I don't know it but it's just it's
like La you know you get used to it so
did you get used to it I got used to it
how did you or did you get get to start
kind of being involved with them yeah I
just started maneuvering like because he
my boy's family is involved in that my
family there are field workers they they
worked on sugarcane
um Agave which would you make tequila
from
um corn like in that area that's what
they do and that's what my family does
and even in the US like they came here
and that's what they did they they work
in the fields and or all my family works
over here all my family works
construction if you're a man you're in
the carpenters union and my boys his his
family they're all involved in that so I
mean Mexico is different because like
your neighbor
this Fool's a hitman
this neighbor he's a politician and and
they'll like have dinner with each other
everything normal everything's normal
even where I lived at I lived in Baja on
my street where I lived at everybody was
like
there was a judge on my street and he
was cool he was cool with me you know
real cool I mean can you talk about what
you were doing with them
I mean honestly like like like my
involvement
see because I'm not I'm not like
bloodline from them and I'm not I wasn't
family so me basically I was just like a
go do this contract that go get go get
this stuff and do this and do that pick
up this give this to this person and
stuff like that or you know I was a
point man or I was there so I was that
and then in other situations yeah you do
get your hands dirty because they want
you to get your hands dirty or
or you know you're not they won't trust
you you know and what's the biggest like
you know in in the media or whatever it
is like like for for Americans that have
no idea what that's really like what the
the culture the cartel culture is or or
or the draw of like work if like the
humanity in it or the lack of it like
what would you say is the biggest
misconception I mean the thing is that
over there there I don't know see I I
want to say that there's less
opportunities that's why people get in
this but I've seen like
I've seen people that are like well off
like crazy like they're their parents
are like
like businessmen and everything they're
all involved in the [__] too you know
it's just like here it's the same as
here it's like
like no one's pushing them into it they
just I don't know they gravitate
not everybody but you know they
gravitate towards it and and next thing
you know that's what they identify as
you know and can you try to explain to
me what the draw is uh I I mean I know I
mean yeah for somebody whose parents are
who has everything like for me
I just was trying to like eat and have
some money and and then that first plan
that was the plan that plan faded away
that that plan didn't matter no more and
I was just like
man we it's survival mode now
you know that because how does one lead
into the other okay look when I first
got there in the early 2000s
you could I talked even I talked about
this with that Calderon he um
you could get 15K 10K to drop somebody
you know right now you're on salary like
500 a week and you might take out like
five people kidnap a family two ATM
machines your job is complicated and go
at it with the cops you know go at it
with you in like because there's so many
people willing to do the work now yeah
yeah it's in this like cheap labor and
then they hire smokers to to do [__] so
it's like like I've seen it happening
you know
but so we just at that point we're just
like man we need to stay out of that and
and just try to get money and and just
stay free you know as long as we can you
know and besides that that thing that
you said happened to you where those
guys saw when those guys surrounded you
and you're like let me just fight him oh
no that's that's like I know that was
just a little but I understand that but
I'm saying what I'm saying is how do you
become a dude that is trusted by these
guys to say hey this is the kind of guy
that could get five to ten thousand
actually you know do this big big job
for us like how do you earn their trust
I mean I don't think you ever do because
even that even them they're um
disposable too they're they're they're
all the people that I knew over there
I'll say like 85 are gone already
they're either their M.I.A they're dead
they're they're over they got indicted
they're over here in the U.S doing life
like
like their shit's not even guaranteed
nothing's guaranteed over there you know
like the cops are corrupt and then they
got good cops and then they got cops
that don't know they're corrupt they're
doing their job but they're working for
someone the work but they don't know
because their boss works for somebody so
their buses go go hit that house but
they're really hitting their enemy's
house somebody else is you know so how
many years are you there I was there 15
years wow so you know in those right
yeah that's what's that you was on the
run during that whole 15 15 years and
you know the the whole time I was I was
I dropped 80 albums I was recording
music crazy when I was over there you
got the pressure of being on the Run
being wanted for murder and then is
there also there's also this pressure of
your enemies or the things that you've
done coming back to haunt you over there
yeah no there is and at the same time
it's like you're living your life like
like [__] that happens in your in
regular you got to deal with all the
life things too like regular life [__]
like life things were happy happening
over there like regular life things you
know it's not all like
[__] Narco season two and [__] you
know it's not all that it's it's life
and then and love and sadness and all
these like things that mess with your
heart and life's changing and you're
changing too you know my boy here came
out the feds I met him over there
and um
he's like hey we have a group where it's
all all nothing but homies but they
learned all the ceremonies they're in
the feds directly from the lakota's from
the Seuss and we run our own sweat lodge
over here and uh and and you know we're
inviting you we it's private no one's
not allowed to come but we're inviting
you you know because he knew that I was
all [__] up this [__] [__] [__] I
had a lot of problems so they invited me
to the sweat lodge right
and when I get there they tell me you
know what we're gonna run this sweat
we're gonna run this sweat for your
sister
and um we you know I I had to sweat it
in a lot of years because I had sweater
with the with the Lakota as long as my
boy wrote a book and he was real close
with the Lakota so he took me to a sweat
with them a long time ago
so I go to the sweat and um man [__] was
hot as [__] like satanic level like tell
me about that we're going through that
so we go to the sweat you know round one
kicks in boom and [__] gets hot as [__]
where are you like I'm in Baja I'm like
right on the beach this area is called
Baja Malibu walk us through like people
who don't know what a sweat lodge is
like sweat lodge is like this it's like
a ceremony it's like this um
they're calling nippies in Spanish they
and you know
where it's basically like like like they
put these Hot Rocks they heat these
rocks and they put them in the middle
and then they pour the water on it and
then it's like a ceremony inside it's
sort of like the tint but it's like
round it's almost like an igloo but it's
like they make it out of Willow because
you could ban Willow and then they cover
it all with blankets and then in there
you know they're drumming they're
singing these songs and then you know
you like invoking the ancestors and
basically it represents going back into
the womb
so you go back into the womb or the
Earth and then you sweat and then and
then you know a lot of things happen in
there like you know it's psychological
too because you start hearing voices in
your like me that's my experience I
don't know if everybody
like me I'm in there and all my problems
like all my demons come out in round one
because it was hot as [__] how long is
round one maybe about 20 25 minutes as
hot as [__] so the whole sweat's about
like two hours
you know because in between they take a
break they open up the wind the the door
and then while they're bringing in the
next set of rocks so every round was
getting hotter and hotter you know
and like by round three I'm out I'm
almost laid out on the floor like I've
been shot or something you know and and
so I'm saying like it's like you're out
to me it's like a test because some
people tap out you know but you're not
allowed to tap out with the homies
because it's like almost like a sign of
disrespect you know like nah we're in
here because basically you're going like
the way they they the way I learned it
from them they're in there to suffer for
to suffer and and and
you know so you're in their suffering
you know you're in there like for the
ones that were here the ones that are
here now and the ones that are yet to
come and and you know your ancestors and
all this stuff you're hearing all these
things but all your problems pop out
right there for me and they're in I feel
like they were in the sweat lodge with
me you know
and then um
like I said they ran that sweat for my
sister
so every like man we're gonna we're here
to sacrifice and and
they kept on bringing on my sister and
and you know it was beautiful it was
hard it was man that's one of the
hottest sweats I've ever been in you
know like I could name three and that
was one other one it was hot as [__] and
and it took everything out of me
everything everything like basically
almost dragged me out of there after it
was done
and then it was right next to the ocean
so we just go jump into the ocean and um
and it's crazy because nine months later
my sister had her son Matthias and we
always call him the sweat lodge baby
yeah nine months later exactly you know
so
and and it was things like that like
spirituality started coming into the
picture you know
and and I already have been initiated
into the African religions one by where
Nigeria the other one by way of the
Congo Angola whatever and and they're
giving me hope I was new so I was like
well what to say what's what the God's
talking about am I straight oh yeah if
you do this if you do that and and you
know but it's full of like um charlatans
too you know so but me I'm a reader I
like to read and study you know so I
started like you know studying and find
out that it's real practical just
because it's it's like it's your Reuben
or spoken in Nigerian you think you're
hearing all this [__] you're like the
[__] are they saying you know it sounds
like like how somebody would say he's
talking Chinese or what but you know
you're in this African language but when
you really break it down and you
translate it it's just you're just
venerating like like
like the world like everything in it the
water the the air the you know fire like
you just you know you're just some
giving
thanks to the gods for all these all
these things that we we don't even give
a [__] about them you know we take them
for granted and [__] and and then so you
know I started sweating
and I started I ended up sweating like
for like 76 years seven years I don't
know like once a month I was sweat I
would just sweat it I I got like
addicted to it like you still do it yeah
I mean I don't do it as much as as as as
I used to and as I can because now it's
in Bala so it's it's a mission for me
but they're still running on the same
everything's still everything's still
running you know but I think that was
like a change and then all these dudes
that I'm around they're all spiritual
but all these dudes are ex Killers X
dope dealers all of them all of them had
all of them that came from the feds 125
130 115 110 all of them had double digit
numbers like behind behind them you know
so and I like that you know what even
the African religion is like I told you
like it'd be like hitman's prostitutes
[__]
you know government officials in the
religion I'll be like man I like this
because there's nobody tripping on
nobody I could be next to this guy
he don't care and now I'm homies with a
[__]
Governor's assistant and I'm my boy's a
cop right here and now this [__] I'm
using all this [__] to my advantage now
like it's keeping me up on game because
I'm still a fugitive I'm still got all
these issues still going on but now it's
like
now they're my people another like
they're like giving me insight and and
hey well look it's about to get hot
right now there's this and that or or or
I just listen without asking and I hear
things you know and I'm like oh [__]
it's time for me to you know
go on the ground again for a little bit
or whatever you know in your life I see
you did a lot of soul searching yeah
trying to find direction
have it ever been that moment in that 15
years where you thought it was over with
yeah it's coming up
but I still have problems so I still
have to keep that I have to keep that in
the cut just in case I needed Plan B
Plan B I always have to be
in here somewhere in case I needed to
reach for Plan B
so
so plan B being I'm gonna take the fight
to them yeah yeah if if I have no choice
because sometimes they'll you get
cornered in over there if you don't do
plan a you're most likely going to get
cornered in with Plan B so
and sometimes you do plan a and they
know where you're going so plan B chases
you to wherever you your destination I
didn't say but a lot of people are dying
through this whole time you know they're
dying they're going M.I.A a lot a lot of
things are happening you know and and
still the government's still there I'm
still hearing rumors from over here from
the U.S I'm talking to people and
they're like man they they you know they
hit the homie's house and they were
asking about you you know this happened
this happened and your name keeps like
so I'm that all that [__] has me worried
so two months in my my daughter's mom's
like I can't deal with this [__] here's
your daughter I'm out
so now I have a baby a baby girl and now
I'm on I'm like now it's like I have the
thing in the diaper bag with my daughter
I'm on the stroller with the [__] right
there like I'm and and that's when I go
out because I'm not really trying to go
out you know only when I have to and
with a pistol and a baby bag right yeah
the thing in the baby bag the diaper bag
so and you know and and sometimes I'll
have the thing on my daughter's back in
the baby chair I'll put in the chair and
put it because over there in Mexico it's
like you might make a right turn there's
a [__] military checkpoint right
there they have like makeshift
checkpoints everywhere you know so you
never know
so
I would wing it man like I'll go like a
good instinct
do I keep it on me right next to me or
should I get through this point if I if
I can make it across this part then I'll
pull it I'll have it with me so I'll
I'll like try to be something but do you
know at this point specifically who it
is that's coming for you yeah yeah you
know who they are yeah yeah there's
there's and then
it's crazy because I had this this dude
that I thought he was my friend you know
he I mean I didn't grow up with him you
know but I met him over there whatever
it was cool
and then um there's a different
situation
and um I already had my daughter and she
was about like
I don't know maybe two going on three
you know we're I have my own my own
house I live in a gated community like
gated Street one time this do see over
there everybody sheisty in it's almost
like here it it I mean it is like here
humans are humans no matter where
they're at you know
but he planted a seed in in another
friend of mine's head that I should be
God
that I should be killed
so I knew I knew a guy that was a squad
leader he was a killer
he had a whole team he was like a SWAT
team dude
I mean he wasn't a real SWAT team but he
had a SWAT team he was trained like a
SWAT team he had a whole crew
and then they sent one of his guys to my
house one day
and this guy he he was below me like he
would do errands for me you know and he
came and he was asking and right when he
asked like the second question first
question second question I was like oh
[__] what the [__] going on right here
you knew it I knew it I would I knew I
knew I was on the list man I was just
like I was just tripping out it was just
going through my head it got resolved
like four or five days later you know
they killed it it ended but but I was
hurt like I said I was like man that's
[__] up [__] this fool I never [__]
with this fool changed my numbers and
everything right later this dude this
individual pops up in my story again
and this time some [__] happened to him
but he has he has no way to get like he
has no way to get his run back no way so
he's like I'll go to Rabbit [__] rabbit
and it was strange because I went to
church that day because you know what
like I was just I was like a pagan I
believed in everything like I was I was
all involved in African religions I was
sweating I was doing everything and and
you know my mom she's Christian you know
so like in my head I I could hear my
mom's voice telling me man you better
take that little girl to church she need
you guys need God and um you know I
could that's how my mom is she always
bringing up church for everything man
you need to pray more you need to go to
church man God don't like this so I
would just take my daughter to church
right and it was it was this big ass
Church it used to be like a boxing arena
so the the seats went down like this and
it was like modern as [__] it was even
on online
so I would never sit with the people I
would you catch if if I ever pop out on
some of this footage I probably am
because they would sometimes like swing
the camera like this and I'll do some
[__] like this like oh here it comes
I'll do this [__] I'll be in the corner
by myself like there'll be probably like
200 seats between me and all the people
and the people that the church dudes
would always be like man you need to sit
over there with the people I'm like no
I'm not you need to or when I ask you to
leave I'm like [__] it I'll leave and
then they'll be like no no just stay and
then I would go to this church right
sometimes I wouldn't pay attention I I
just being there texting doing all my
business they're trying to get money and
do whatever inside the church and it was
good for me because I could hide in
there I was hiding in plain sight and I
had some friends there at the church and
I remember they did this like Christian
baptism it's different than a Catholic
baptism they in Christians they like
present the child to God or something
and they they were like it was it was
happening one day you know but I
couldn't do it because the shit's online
this is a modern ass church this should
look like a show like I could do a rap
show here like big ass screen light all
kinds of [__] you know but I couldn't do
it so I told my friend like hey can you
and your wife do my daughter like go in
and present her to God like I need that
and they're like yeah yeah we got you so
even that was part of my my soul
searching because sometimes I go to
church and I feel like God was like
talking directly to me like they'll say
some [__] and I'll be like what the [__]
man this one knows what I'm going
through like he'll like say [__] like
yeah I know it seems [__] up right now
but you know you're gonna make it out of
here and then he'll like I like [__] out
of Psalms because like it just gives me
like 42 like what I was telling you
about the Quran I would read the Quran I
just be feel strong when I read the
Quran because I would read it like
that's how I would read the Quran me I
don't know
you know and and and it just I was I was
just reading I became an Avid Reader it
was almost like I was in prison because
my house was my cell I wouldn't really
come out I had to jam all in my house
had a PlayStation room in there
recording studio I came out when I had
to and I just was exercising and reading
exercising reading exercising reading
making music and making music
so this one day I go to church right
it's on a Sunday
we had this little routine church and
then we go to this like [__] fake boy
or local right and it was bomb
go get it we eat [__] my daughter
take a nap she go to her room and go to
my room take naps and then we'd come out
after like I'll go out there and play
with her and you know on a little
bicycle whatever right
so I'm like man I'm gonna wash my car I
had this SUV so I'm [__] watching it
I have the thing and the the thing open
in the back right
and then it's a gated street so Sunday
my street was dead nobody would go out
no cars would come in like you know
fools were hungover I don't know out of
town whatever
and um
boom two SUVs one SUV pulled two of them
but one pulls up directly in front of
the gate and they're just looking at me
and I'm like man so I keep washing the
car and every time I look like I try to
like do some [__] like that like out the
corner of my eye [__] looking at me
like grilling me giving me dirty looks
like say something where's your daughter
at right there playing right in front of
me like she's just a little girl she's
playing
so they're just looking at me and I'm
like man
[__] and I'm acting dumb I'm washing the
car so I gave my daughter put her inside
I go to my kitchen I jump up on the
counter I go over the cabinets and I get
the thing and I bring it out and I put
in the back under the towels and I keep
washing the car and they're just [__]
looking at me and I was like
like maybe five or ten minutes I don't
know how many minutes have passed but it
seems long because they're just looking
at me
and it's obvious there's no one on the
streets and then what they're waiting
for is someone to come in so the gate
could open so they could drive through
or you know vice versa leave or come in
so I know this I'm like man these fools
are waiting to come in but I'm thinking
like man I'm tripping maybe it's not for
me because I've been paranoid by this
time [__] over a decade everything
means something to me everything
everything adds up to something else and
and and I already been a decade by this
time you already you know you got
callous you know things and [__] you
know how things work and how things
operate
it's about to go down like [__] so you
start thinking and and so
they just leave I'm tripping it wasn't
for me maybe they're at the wrong Street
and they just called them oh you're on
the wrong Street come come down two more
streets but they never come back up so
now another car comes it looks at me and
it does a U-turn and now it's on my side
of the gate
so the dude gets out
and uh he's calling me he's like hey to
come out there
I really recognize them I get close and
it's the dude that try to have me killed
the first time
from before
so I look at them and um I'm like nah
it's hot out there with the what they
call them the people so peoples are the
state police those are the ones that
catch fugitives they have some like an
iPad where you put your hand on it it
looks like on some Interpol [__] or
something I I never really seen it but I
just heard it from other people that
were telling me they got that they got
that iPad where you put your hand on it
and they had some [__] where they like
even if you race everything out of your
phone they'll plug this [__] back in
it'll bring everything right back up
they had all this like technology you
know and and these dudes were like
Denzel Washington it's like training day
like and met and they roll in two trucks
so it's like eight of them so imagine
eight Denzel Washington's
jumping out on you and [__]
interrogating they're all asking you the
same question in a different way where
you live at and they'll go to your house
Rob your house depends right so I tell
them it's hot with the peppers I Buzz
them in he comes in
and um he starts trying to play with my
daughter and I'm like man something
ain't right like why is he here
why is he in my house like why the [__]
is this who here he's trying to play
with my daughter he's like beating
around the bush
and then he's telling my daughter kick
kick punch because I you know my
daughter used to watch me train so it
kicks you do it when she was little
and I'm like man get the [__] away from
my daughter like in my head like
fool I know him he's shyster as [__]
so this so then he starts he asked me
for one of my boys
hey what's up with your boy have you
talked to him like nah talk to him like
in three or four months why what's up
he's like man some [__] happened
so basically
some stuff went missing that was like uh
half a meal ticket like
um like and some change it went missing
right and then he's like man
you know you know I'm not with these
people no more I'm with these people
he's with a different set of people now
you know people on the border they know
they're going to hear they say I know
what I'm talking about
so the people that was they weren't they
didn't have that power no more it was
more this new crowd that came in
so he's like I'm with them and I'm I'm
telling them like that's cool man I'm on
the sidelines I don't I'm not tripping
or none of that you know I do my [__] on
my own I don't and then he's just going
on and on and then he goes and tells the
next thing he tells me is like look man
look rabbit I'm gonna tell you some [__]
it's gonna [__] you up
but
I have no choice
and I and he goes I told on your boy to
the pfp to the Mexican federal police
so when he tells me that they're corrupt
that's nothing my boy was in the U.S so
I'm like who gives a [__] like
that's like
telling on a [__] security guard
like telling some information to a
[__] security guard like what the
[__] is he gonna do nothing but then he
goes I told your boy to the pfp and I
gave him up to the DEA when he said that
oh man I just had like a outer body
experience
oh and by now I have the [__] in my
pocket you know I'm holding my
daughter's hand I have it in my pocket
and I'm just like watching this body
language up and down I'm just reading
this fool like like second he goes I'm
because I'm hearing like voices and my
shit's talking to me it's like kill this
fool when he tells me that man killed
his fool but it's like how are you gonna
kill him on the street gated Street what
I'm neighbors are probably even looking
out the window you know because Mexican
people are nosy like that they you know
looking up the blind see what the [__]
going on out there you know want to know
what's it's probably an old lady all up
in the shed you know but but when he
tells me this it [__] me up it like
like I [__] took the air out of my chest
because I never heard nobody say that
you know like I'm a snitch and I snitch
on your boy but I had to let me explain
why he's telling me this [__] and I'm
like what
and I'm like man and he goes you and
then he tells me you got to help me you
gotta help me get the [__] back or
they're gonna kill me and my wife and
I'm like man they ain't doing nothing I
can help you with you know I don't got
nothing to do with it I want to be
involved in it I'm not involved in it
and he's just telling me all this [__]
and then you know over there everybody
got like five six phones you know so if
I if I were to talk to you
I had a phone just for you one football
one for Prime that's it and in case
something it didn't mix with all the
other lines and I could just throw them
shits away or break the chip
so this dude has all his phones and all
his phones are going off
so I'm like man I I know this but after
that you know you know this food's trash
you know
so then um
he's like his body language he's like
turns around he turns around on me and
he's like hold up hold up he's talking
to the SUV and the dead end they came
together back then I I just assumed and
I had speculations but now I know his
people and I know the other side of the
story so I talked to his people they're
like man they can't get you they want to
kidnap you kill you and your daughter
all that [__] and um and then he's like
so he's on the phone he's like hold up
hold up hold up and he's trying to like
he keeps turn giving his back to me and
I'm like man she's like I just like
I know what to do because my daughter
she's little she can't see that and and
and and I'm already on cruise control
I'm not like I said I have planned it's
gonna plan B's plan to pop up right now
you know I'm on cruise control I'm I'm
over here thinking about the gods and
and I'm reading books and and [__]
the seven hermetic laws and and I'm all
into [__] Sun Tzu and and I'm all
into you know Machiavelli and I'm
reading all these books and and you know
The Four Agreements and I'm on some
other [__] you know I'm trying to be on
some other [__] like and like teaching
all this [__] to my daughter too you
know and like taking her to the sweats I
mean she wouldn't go in there but she'd
be with her with me and like you know
other ceremonies and [__] like that you
know
so finally whatever he left and I was
[__] I was going crazy so I called my
Madrina this is like this is like a a
Santeria priest right
and I and I'm like and you know I need
to see you
so I head up to Otay which is right
there in TJ by the airport
she's like get over here right now and
go over there she does a [__] reading
on me she's like man you got death on
your head look
it says it right here iku is deaf she's
like you got to go on your head
but we could fix this [__]
so don't trip go home you're gonna be
all right I'm like man I ain't [__]
I'm over here so that night was that was
like one of the hardest nights for me
because
I didn't sleep obviously and then my
daughter
I'd say this on the podcast I was
because I can't like you know so my
daughter um you know she had her own
room but she would sleep on my bed you
know she always knock out in my room
so she crawls into my bed that night
and you know I like cover her with a
little baby blanket and then I put a
bulletproof vest on top of her I'm
wearing a bulletproof vest I have the
chopper and I have another Chopper and I
have some handguns and I'm just I'm like
this I'm that I'm that Mexican old lady
now I'm like this by the blinds and I'm
just because I could see the street from
my from the from the from my room and
probably been to my path he knows how it
looks so from my window I can see all
the way to the street so I'm just in the
window I'm walking back and forth I go
down
I'm like my plan was like if they came I
was gonna put my daughter on my
neighbor's roof come back down real
quick and just go at it with these Foods
you know because I had cameras too so I
had cameras in all kinds of places so I
just was like had that had the iPad had
all that [__] and I just was looking
and then you know like I just felt weak
not weak but like
I just felt like um
like we not might we might not make it
through the night you know and I just
was feeling like I felt like taking down
something felt like taking my daughter
to the Border turning her in and turning
myself in because it was just too much
like I was just like losing I was kind
of losing my mind because it it felt
real personal
because he it was like he knew me I knew
him I knew it was most likely going to
happen next and I was just waiting for
it so
so it's like you're waiting to be killed
and you know the the clock is going slow
slow so I'm just like
you know I'm not like like [__]
crying but you know my tears are coming
every time I look at my daughter my
[__] tears are coming out and then I
get mad like man [__] this fool
come I want him to come but then I see
her turn over and she's a she's a little
girl you know and and she's like she's
back then she was real girly and [__]
like princesses and [__] like that and
she like them toys Monster High and all
this you know from those days I don't
know I just was like I don't know if I
probably pray to God I probably pray to
my gods and I just was like
I wanted it to happen almost like come
let's get this [__] over with and [__]
you know like what do I do so the whole
night from about like 8 P.M 9 P.M
to like [__] I didn't sleep until they
came the next day the Madrina
and we ended up doing this crazy
ceremony where where
um it's almost like you trade you feed
the ground uh
like you do a it's like a sacrifice you
feed the ground blood instead of your
blood it gets fed you know the blood of
an animal
and and then she was just like you'll be
all right she did another reading look
you cool it's crazy cuz and then like
three days later the dude leaves a phone
number on my door a paper a little kid
told me he had some guy um told me to
put it right here and I'm and it had his
initial of his first name of his
nickname
so I here I am again walking back and
forth from my kitchen to the living room
back and forth like should I call it
should I use my phone nah cause he I'm
like if this was already with the DEA
and the and the federal police my shit's
gonna be recorded and then I'm thinking
he's gonna just snitch on me so I could
get busted you know I I don't know all
these things were just like
that was a mess you know in my mind like
mentally I was a mess but I had a grip
on it because if not I would have you
know did something stupid but I think I
come from the pay phone but I remember
when I called them he finally answers
and he and he's like hey there's your
new number and I'm like yeah but but it
was it was a pay phone number he's like
don't trip we could talk the line is
clean
and I'm like all right yeah yeah right
but all right what's up and he's like
look man I know what I told you [__]
you up or you need to help me because if
not me and my wife are going to end up
dead and that's almost like man you know
what you take care of yourself bro I
can't and I just clicked on them and I
just went back home
and then I heard he was he he crossed
back on into the U.S you know a little
bit short time after so my life got
peaceful again
but this dude pops up again on me right
before I get arrested in 2016. yeah I
got arrested in 2016. I knew he was back
in town because he had gotten in trouble
with the feds again
see I didn't know this but now I didn't
talk to his people so I know I put all
this [__] together I'm like man and even
even his people tell me my fool you
weren't you weren't in Crazy danger like
that fool was pressing he was pressing
the people to snatch you up badly like
he wanted
you know half a male is half a male man
supposed to be dying for 500 over there
you know half a meal is a lot and um why
why did him having you get killed he
just wanted like he just wanted some
[__] satisfaction some some kind of
paper what did that have to do with the
money nothing nothing he by killing me I
mean maybe you know what he was probably
gonna probably try to do the kid at me
torture me have me call the US and call
my peoples call the neighborhood or
whatever
thinking that they would send some of it
back or send some or all of it get it
all back
that's what I'm thinking you know but
but in the end
the end result was gonna be the end
result you know I wasn't going to walk
away from there I doubt it because he
knows oh
Cornejo is a [__] ninja let's fool
come back and get me you know like I
gotta I would have to get rid of him you
know and if I do something to his
daughter and his food and what would you
do if someone would mess with your kids
or your kids or
you know you become a different person
you know you don't you can't yeah
but but in 2016 he was back over there
and um
one day I come home but I didn't go into
my street I went to the street across
the street because the U.S or no over
there in Mexico
and um
I didn't know I was already under
surveillance they were already watching
me I didn't know this so I go across the
street and there was this truck parked
in front of my house and the dude that
was there was a he's a big he was a big
dude he was like a boss and this fool
responsible for like over like 200
murders or 300 murders he's parked in
front of my house
so again I'm like man I told the The
Gardener the security guard Gardener
slash everything handyman from the
street across I'm like hey how long that
truck been right there he's like three
hours four hours he's just sitting there
texting but I had different cars so they
had probably told them this was in this
but I was in someone some soccer mom
[__] you know so he didn't and then I
went into the other street so I'm my
friend had a three-story house so I'm in
the on the third story just looking at
the dude he don't even know I'm watching
him I'm watching them all that [__] and
um when I seen him I knew that I was in
danger again
because that dude doesn't pop up that
dude be on the news he's he's dangerous
as [__]
not because he'll do it but he has like
he has the the Manpower like to to make
some [__] happen shortly after that I
got I got
they came and they got me and I ended up
back over here in the U.S they got me um
a few I think like two days after
Thanksgiving November 2016. I was going
to turn myself in January 2nd but that
was another thing because I hadn't told
my daughter by now my daughter's like
seven that [__] we're gonna get split up
and we never been split up like that so
that [__] was like [__] with me I
couldn't even I was just all [__] up
and it's crazy because two nights before
I got arrested that night my daughter
see by this time now her mom was back in
the picture you know so we're like you
know she'll stay some days with her mom
some like most of the time with me some
days with her mom
so I remember that night my daughter
came in like two days before she came in
and she told me I love you daddy she
gave me a kiss and she went right back
to her room and then like five minutes
later she came back and she did she did
it like three or four times in a row she
kept coming back and giving me a kiss
and saying good night love you Daddy and
go back to a room and I was like what
the [__] I love this little girl she's
[__] dope like where's this coming
from like we're tight but she was just
being like
you know a little girl you know and and
and and that [__] was [__] with me
even more because I'm like how am I
gonna that we're about to be split up
how can I do this and see look a month
before this would happen
I was in the back in my in back of my
house I had this spot where I would do
all my like rituals and stuff like that
my spirit I practice my spirituality and
I was back there and my boy the one that
was in the feds the one invited me to
sweat lunch for the first time he was a
whim he would help me so we're doing and
I'm and I'm doing like divination I do a
reading and that [__] tells me that's it
your time is up it's time for you to go
and face your issues
and I was like Ah hell no
not yet
and I was like What if I bring you you
know I'll bring you a goat two roosters
and
um some make you some animals you know
because it's like animal sacrifice and
it was like no you're gonna go get me
that anyways and told me like you're
gonna go get me those animals anyways
and uh but don't worry I got you I'm um
you you'll be out
and I was but see you you never know
because you know you you
as much as a Believer you are you're
skeptical you know like or because just
because of life you know you life is
like It's Tricky you know sometimes and
so you don't you don't
you don't know what to expect
two weeks after that this queue induced
down from Mexico City he's this big
santero Oba he's a priest
and um
he does me the ceremony where I receive
this this deity called batala
and then I received Allah it's like a
whole day ceremony
and he does a reading
and then this readings everything's cool
till he gets to the end and he goes oh
[__] someone who you thought was your
friend was never your friend and he's
already betrayed you
so I'm like what the [__] so I don't
really have friends so I'm like is it
the gardener is it my boy
is it the [__] swimming coach is it
the the like like I just had like a
handful of people I really [__] with you
know so
so I'm just think like that [__] was in
my head and then my daughter I was a
mess my boys ran a sweat for me they
knew there was this tattoo shop where
they would hang out at and I would go
over there sometimes low-key and they're
like I want to run a sweat for you so
you could get your mind cleared but that
was one of the hardest sweats I ever
went to too because
I just had so much [__] like um see
there's 15 years I got a lot of weight
on my back I haven't slept in 15 years
wow like good night's sleep I hadn't I
didn't sleep till I hit the [__]
County until I hit Wayside
you know you go to the county process it
takes like two or three days then you
end up in Wayside that's when I slept
three days in a row I didn't sleep in
like 50 yeah I'm not gonna say I didn't
sleep but
I slept like one night you know I always
wanted here so I was just like resting
but not like unless I was [__] drunk
or some [__] or and I got [__] up and
I knocked out but how did they come for
you like how when when you're getting
real Okay so
my boy Chris he's a santero too he's a
he's a priest he's on a bar in the
African religions he's like hey there's
these African dudes down here and um
want to come here Pat and have a jam
session and do like a ritual but like
with the drums you know
and me the I love the drums like the
drums they like put me in the trance so
I'm like yeah yeah yeah so I started
cleaning up my pad and everything right
and but for like a month I started
seeing cars because I had cameras across
the street all over the place and at
this point there's you're not really
putting in any work for the cartel
anymore right I mean no I'm not I'm not
see look I was never like direct with
the cartel I was just always direct with
dudes that got money independent however
you could but I knew a lot of cartel
dudes from different cartels I I knew
you you just get to know them you know
or or because oh they're even dudes flip
a lot like he might be from this one for
three years and then oh these ones are
going down and these guys made to a deal
now you're over there son
I might have known you being from three
cartels and [__] right you know so I'm
on cruise control I I just I have plan B
in the cut that's all I just want to
like protect my daughter
like anybody like you know I'm saying at
the end of the day we just want to
protect the ones we love and that's it
and and try to make it and I was gonna
turn myself in I'm in love with my girl
all these things are in my head like
feelings and emotions and and I'm
getting older now so I don't think the
same now I'm like
so I'm cleaning I got a big black trash
bag and it's a gated street right so the
the trash bin you got to come out the
gate make a left and then over there and
then you gotta unlock it and then you
throw it in you lock it back up
so right before I was gonna go I'm like
nah let me check the camera so I get the
the like the iPad thing and I start
checking all the cameras and there's a
[__] car right there with two dudes
sitting in it and I'm like and they
don't know I have a camera right on top
of them so I could see straight down
that they're texting and they're running
[__] on a notepad they're taking notes I
can't see what they're texting because
they like 4K like right now or 6K or
whatever but I could see what they're
doing
so I'm waiting and waiting I'm looking
out the window I'm just like man these
[__] won't leave so like an
hour passes by I'm like man I'm tripping
I've been tripping for 15 years it's
probably nothing I tell myself that
it's just my [__] the PTSD
so here I come with the trash bag right
when I get to the gate I buzz it open
and then I make that left and I look out
the corner of my eye and they're [__]
looking at me like crazy you know I got
my glasses on but I'm like all right
these foods are straight looking at me
so I don't even put the track the trash
in the in the trash can I just throw it
by the side
and then I buzz it again so the gate
starts closing so that way I could get
in in case of anything
put this [__] from right as soon as I do
that from The Click
to me getting the rest is probably like
15 seconds 10 seconds now it's going
already it's about to happen
so as I come through the gate I take
about one to maybe two steps I just see
a big ass Dodge Ram coming straight at
me boom it knocks the gate off the rail
so I jump out the way because it's a big
ass and it's sort of like a little down
slope so the doors coming at me the
truck that's just flying out there so
when I jump out the way the two fools in
the car they're already running towards
me food tackles me
and I hear him say cuff his feet he's
gonna kick
because
like I didn't mentioned this but before
there was like this there's like a
Mexican YMCA over there in TJ right
and I have met this instructor he was a
shito Japanese karate and and I have
become his assistant instructor I was I
did Japanese uh karate almost four or
five years so I would like we would we
would teach all the like at-risk youth
that's how that's how I felt like I was
giving back because these were all like
Hood kids they had no money he's
supposed to come with like 20 pesos a
month which is equal to like a dollar
and I'll put the rest for them or I'll
do you know and I was buying all the
head gear you know and like just
pitching in for them because they were
like Street kids you know so I'm like
so these guys already have seen they
they were they had their surveillance on
me they were watching me telling me all
that [__] so when they tackled me I
heard that cuff his feet he's gonna kick
so they cuffed my feet when they
attacked me to the ground but then they
like put the other
you know guns on my head don't move like
in Spanish you know don't move
[__] will smoke your ass which
is really American nah they were Mexican
Americans can't go in the U.S like that
they can't have guns and like the
everything yeah could go in but they
can't have guns they could just
watch I'm sure like for Chapo and them
they do go in but they're dressed as
Mexican Marines or Mexican uh military
because if you see when they get like
big time dudes they're winning ski masks
Mexican foods don't give a [__] like
whatever so what'd you feel I mean like
what I thought it was I thought it was
the dude that was parked outside my
house I thought I was about to die
so they get me because it's like a
kidnapping they didn't show me no bad it
happens it happened in an instant it's
like an explosion the way it happened
boom
they snatched me up they cover my head I
can't see throw me in the truck they
cuff my feet to the bottom of the truck
so I can't jump out
and they're just holding my head down
and they're just like trying to like
Punk me like like
I don't move you know like but in
Spanish sound crazy you know like
there's this and that and and then um
we're gone and I could hear you know
we're making by the way the engine revs
up and I know we're making Labs rights
because I drove around there so I know
left right right left so I'm thinking oh
they're gonna take me to a like uh they
call Casas like security
like like cartel fools or cops have them
where they do all their dirty work
they'll take you to one of them pads and
they'll go to work on you you know
so I'm thinking it's crazy because my
boy that runs a sweat lodge he will run
him super hot and Hammer he told us one
day I run him like this so if case one
day you guys get tortured you guys can
handle it so that [__] popped up in my
head like man we're about to go to one
of those pads and I've been in them pads
I'd seen what they do to people I've
seen what happens to they drilling you
they [__] chainsawing you you know
anything skill saw you
a lot of [__] happens to you you know
and um
but after a few minutes whatever
whatever
I seen a packet on the floor
of papers you know they uncover my head
I see the packet I see my face right
there but it don't matter because the
the bad guy is doing telling you too so
you never know but then that's when you
tell he's like hey in Spanish he's like
what's up
and I didn't like reply to him in any
semi-real name and I didn't reply to him
and then they're like look bro like we
don't even give a [__] about you for
reals like the US came over here they
[__] they hit us with the folder he's
there can you bring them to us now we
don't care about because they they don't
I know I knew cops over there that will
catch fugitives so I would I was asking
questions he's like man I don't give a
[__] what the us talking about we do it
when it's just like
they already told on them someone told
on them and it's obvious and we got to
get them and turn them over to the U.S
but these fools honestly the way they
got me
and I was with them riding around in the
truck they didn't go and turn me in
right away these fools were scheming
they got all kinds of [__] going on hey
meet us at the spot is everything ready
like this [__] was like straight like
training day you know when they're
getting ready to hit that house that
were the one dudes that that older dude
and they're getting ready and they meet
somewhere I was at a meeting point with
them somewhere I was just in the truck
but they're like meeting up and and and
I know the language
so they don't care about me so then you
know they take you to um
to the command center whatever
and that's that picture that picture
where I'm where I'm like that with no
shirt on that's where they took that
picture but they they were they were
kind of cool because it's somewhere
along there they let me make a phone
call and go can I make can I call my
daughter she's in school
and they're like What's the number and I
don't know and I gave him the name they
Googled it they um they got the number
they called it the principal answered
and I was like yeah
so they wouldn't got her and then my
daughter got on the phone and I'm like
Mommy
um something happened and the police got
me they're going to take me back to
where Grandma's at and my daughter
started screaming and crying so I you
know I should like weakened me right
there you know to hear scream that way
because I never heard her scream like
that that's like if you see a [__]
goal like ah some [__] [__] and then
crying her first initial reaction was
scream and then cried no no no no no and
I told her like well you know what
you're a big girl don't worry tell the
principal to call your mom
that you want to go home and then I'm
gonna have Grandma and I'm gonna have uh
your deal your tia they're going to call
you but relax calm down and she was
listening to me I calmed her down but
she was still crying and that's what
happened and then then they take you to
the Border this is long concrete walk
where like where you're like you know
your waist you shackle from the waist
you know you're like you do that walk
they always when every time they catch
fugitives you see them they do that walk
and they turn you over to like eyes
Homeland Security uh I think
with CBP something border patrol they're
all right there [__] um they sent me
down in the lobby it was crazy because
it was like regular people they take
their they took all their [__] from me
I'm just sitting there I don't even
think I was cuffed and the dude the
dude's like what's your name and it's
crazy because I didn't I didn't use my
name in 15 years and you know you're
social and I'm like yeah hold on hold on
and I was trying to remember how it goes
he's like nah there's nothing here
and I was like oh [__] maybe not even
want it what the [__] maybe I'm like man
I feel stupid if I was on the run for 15
years and I wasn't wanted what the [__]
and it's just something you just would
sit there want to see and he was
checking and now we're passed by all of
a sudden he's like oh this guy needs to
be over there and they came and they
cuffed me again they put me they cuffed
me to a bench
and then I'm on this bench and there was
like a senior like this old white dude
like one of those like [__] a dick
you know
and then he's like he comes in he's like
what the [__] is this guy doing here
uh-uh this dude needs to be in a Cell
already this is not like this dude's not
here for like some drunk in public in
Mexico this is being there
so they that was the first cell I went
into once I went into that cell I was
like oh man this is it that's how it
starts look at this [__] you know
[__] metal sink and toilet you know
what what a cell looks like you know
and I'm in there I'm just like [__] let
me do some push-ups
because it was freezing they had that AC
blowing so I'm like and I had a hoodie
and everything
and then like two hours later
um LAPD the The Fugitive task force
pulls up like they had they were in
Vegas
um sitting on somebody trying to catch
somebody within Vegas
and they got the call hey we got Conejo
so they smashed all the way to TJ and
they they came and they just like picked
me up
and then we drove to 77th division oh
wow so we're [__] um I remember we're
driving on the I think it was the five
maybe the eight or five I don't know one
of those but I remember I'm just like
looking at all these like Red Robin
um Carl's Jr I'm just seeing all this
[__] on the way there I'm in the little
like minivan with one chair there's one
chair in the back and the dudes in the
back and he's just like hey don't [__]
around
let's just make it a smooth ride but I'm
like cuffed like this so I can't do
nothing you know really
and and in my head I'm like you know
like
it was kind of like almost like a sign
of relief like that was just so many
years of all that weight on me you know
so it's just like
I wasn't happy but but I was just like
in nostalgic that drive because we made
it from over there to to 77th in one
hour they were smashing we were like a
caravan like three cars and you know
right there in San Clemente they got
that other little checkpoint right there
that shit's never [__] open I mean
that shit's never closed like they were
out there that day so we pulled up they
flashed their lives they did some kind
of symbols
flashed a bachelor like go go go go go
go boom we get to 77th division
cold ass night I remember those colds
chilly one of those like it was November
so it was kind of you know like that
cold air
77 is [__] wild you step in there and
I'm just like ah it's a [__] crack
cake about to get processed next to me
like all these weird ass dudes and [__]
and and the process starts you know I go
to the day I find I finally end up in a
sale by myself
I'm like can I use the phone they brung
me down I only knew one number because
you know I memorized my girl's number so
I call it
she gives me a couple other numbers I
start calling they put me in like a
little tank at 77 so I'm calling any
number I can't hey do me a three-wheel
call it give me a number whatever
I go back to my cell you know I think
it's becoming the next day or it does
become the next day and they're like hey
um we're gonna clean your cell we're
gonna move you to this other cell
so I had a boy that he was on the Run 20
years they had caught him two months
before me off of Adams too like Adams
and you know Maple and you know all
those right there and when they took him
to 77 there's a thing called Perkins
they'll put an informant in your cell
with you
it's a it's like a tactic they they use
Perkins I don't know if you it made a
big deal because in in Orange County
they were using it
so they put an informant in there and
they asked them all these questions and
this fool ended up talking to us about
his case tool he might have been that
straight LAPD but me they put me in the
cell with a dude that has all his arms
full of tracks it's hero netting he has
[__] track marks all over his arms
and they put me in there and I got a
hoodie on I still got my street clothes
and then um you know like the first
thing he asked me he's like what you in
here for rape he tells me like that I
want to [__] this fool up I'm like what
and but I already knew like okay the
camera's right there
you know they could hear the speakers on
the wall I'm like oh this is this where
the setup starts and I'm just I'm like
what oh no no no I apologize whatever he
says some [__] because he's seen that I
like kind of like I'm about to stomp him
out and then he starts asking me about
people like he didn't know who I was I
didn't introduce myself to him because I
was like the [__] this was a smoker what
the [__] I'm gonna tell him who I am or
anything give him any info you know he's
nobody to me and and then he starts
bringing up people that I know
he's like hey you know your homeboy this
and I'm just like what
how you know him and then he's like yeah
you know he sells dope over here on this
street he starts telling me he's
throwing all these things out you know
and I'm like oh is that right all right
cool I'm not answering none of his [__]
well when I was at 77 my attorney
already had came to see me it was
already in place everything so he's like
man just um you know fall back chill
don't talk to nobody about your case I'm
on it already don't worry about it I
might not make it to the first court
date so don't freak out if you don't see
me there so I go to that first court day
and I have a public defender it's a lady
and I'm right tell her hey
do I get bail and she's like nah there's
no bail for death penalty cases and that
says another out of body experience that
[__] [__] me up you know she's like
there is no bill for those type of cases
and everybody in the tank
everybody in the Tank's like oh [__]
like everybody's just quiet like oh
because you know this damn it was some
there was homies in there you know that
I ended up running into them later you
might know I'll tell you that you know
him he's an old school homie you might
know him
because he was in the feds
and um and then he knew me already
everybody when I stepped in the county
everybody knew me your name carried his
weight yeah so they were just like man
you know whatever whatever and then you
know and that it was kind of strange for
me too because like I said I haven't
used my real name
Jose in 15 years I've been this I've
been that I've been all these other
names
and now I'm back to like I'm Jose again
and then I never when I was on the run
I'll never tell nobody I was from
heartbeat so they call me Conejo rabbit
whatever never I'll never I just like I
because there was informants over there
you know that would trade in for to get
the green cards to come back to the U.S
or you know like there was a lot a lot
of like
that going on so
I go through the I go back now now from
from core you go to the county and
that's when you get processed into the
county and I get to the county and
everybody's like the same thing man this
food's like oh [__] [__] rabbits
right here with us or whatever
and everybody's like Mom you're gonna go
to high power they're not going to keep
you in like GP you're gonna go up there
and I'm like man I'm not that's it again
I'm like I'm not a celebrity like that
um you know I'm just like you guys I
just I'm I'm just a regular Homie Ain't
no ain't no like I don't feel like a
celebrity or none of that [__]
and and nothing happened I end up you
know you go in the county for like two
or three days they moving you up and
down and this this then they ship me out
to Wayside super max
and that's when I knocked out for like
three days I was tired I was just super
tired I just slept for like three days I
just get up to eat and go right back to
sleep and the homies was like cool with
it you know because you're not really
you're not supposed to like sleep in the
day you know but they knew I had came
from like
basically like War you know I needed
some rest
and that was it I just I stayed in there
for like a year and a half fighting as a
matter of fact I never left the Raymond
I went home from a Raymond I never went
to preliminary they just postponed
postpone postpone
for a year and a half and then one day I
went to court
and uh my attorney shout out to us
Stuart gold Farm she's crazy because
I'll call Dave right I was calling Dave
from the county so I called Dave one day
and how do you know how did you find the
same neighborhood and Dave grew up like
two blocks away from me okay and so you
knew rich and you knew all yeah yeah I
used to train with Rich all that
everything like when did you first meet
him because he didn't go like he moved
there from foster care right like he did
he grow up down there he grew up like
his later teenage years later but he's
older than me yeah but Dave's I just see
Dave walking down like he was like Dave
was banged out back then honestly Dave
you'll see Dave a white guy with a pen
but see look there's a thing in the
neighborhood there's a family of
Brothers they're a white family and they
were all from harpies somehow I don't
know why but I always thought Dave was
maybe he's from there he's one of their
those Brothers all these fools have blue
eyes they were all they're all but all
these fools end up like Fool's got life
and everything they were all banged out
but I was just assumed Dave was a dude
that just walked by like I see him I was
a little kid
you know so I see these faces you know
later we connect later when I'm as I'm
older you know and then um
but like like I said I'll call Dave from
the county right
and this was like six months before I
went home I didn't know I was going home
I'm fighting life now now the death
penalty is off now it's just life so I
called Dave and Dave's like hey if you
could come home before April you're on
family crimes my new series he's telling
me this [__] and I'm like bro they're
trying to give me life
like I don't know if I'm gonna make it
home by April
but it's crazy because I came home in
February
like I came home before even that you
know and and I you know I used to call
them and say whatever and then um so one
day my attorney came
attorney visit like unexpectedly and I'm
like oh [__] I got my [__] went to the
attorney visit to the visiting room now
and I was in medium North I only stayed
in super max I would say if it wasn't a
month it was two months two court dates
at the most
and then they shipped me to medium North
it's still in the L.A county jail but
it's called medium North
and then um so they he came to see me
and he goes I got good news and I got
bad news and I was like man just tell me
the bad news
and he's like they just offered you
three years
and I'm like that's bad news that's good
news because I already been here a year
and a half I would only do like another
15 months and I'm home I'm like I'm
taking it he's like
the good news is that that tells me I
could beat this [__] I could get you a
way better deal where I could beat this
[__] and they'll he always had told me
he's like they have a marginal case at
best against you you know and and I was
never like cocky about it it felt a
little bit good but I never like like
I'm winning I never because there's
dudes that
that that felt like that and I remember
there was this dude in there he was from
Hoover I want to say they called them
rat rat rat boy old school dude this
dude had just he had went proper and
beat a murder case wow and then they
charged them with another one he's an
old dude too
and but he was like a [__] lawyer and
he ended up in my dorm but my dorm was
uh
a neighborhood dorm I think it was like
the 60s or 30s it's like that that's the
Crips that were in there
so everybody would go to him and kind of
like Get Some Like legal advice from him
and and Amber had told him I had like
sat down one of them I brought him some
offerings like look I'm gonna tell you
my case what you think and he's like man
you're going home
Maybe not today and maybe not tomorrow
but you're going home I'm like all right
cool so but still I never like um
I never like took anything for granted I
just try to stay humble stay out of the
way and and you know like you know just
be respectful and and just be quiet and
just you know do my [__] and focus on my
case and um so the attorney goes and he
tells me that
and I'm like nah I'm just gonna take
those three years and he's like nah he
doesn't and and you know my he's Jewish
you know and I was like I just I always
feel like Jewish returns they're the
best you know and like that's God's
chosen people and [__] like you know and
and and at one point he's from he's
really from like the East Coast so so he
come like to he'd be like Shalom babe
and I'll be like Shalom you know he like
would pound on the glass and then um
nah nah I'm taking him he was arguing
with me I'm like no it's my [__] I'ma
take it so then
you know me and my girl are making plans
and [__] like look we're over there like
calculating if I take the three years
and then I'm gonna have like this much
time but if I do this one little program
they're gonna knock off so I can maybe I
could get out of there in 11 months 10
months the day before I go to my last
court date I call them 2 I'm taking that
deal Jose you're not yeah I am we're
like going back and forth I'm taking
that deal
and he's like no he's just we're not
bumping heads but we're just like a
little tug of war right
so I get to court the next day right see
Courts at like nine I always be the
first guy in court CCB I was in a
Division I think 31 or 33 I'm not sure
and um I would always be the first guy
because I had a real attorney all the
public defender guys like they might be
in that tank for five hours before they
they see him or three hours or some [__]
right so he comes in Shalom all that
Shalom and then um he's like hey I got
you a better deal you'll be home by 7
p.m tonight I'm like what the whole
[__] the whole tank was like it was
like boom like and I'm like what is it
well we're gonna please you down to
voluntary manslaughter we're going to
give you a six-year sentence suspended
and five years probation and I'm like
[__] it let's go so I came out to corn
and the judge like you sure you want to
take this deal I'm like yeah my mom and
my sister like my mom's crying my mom I
can't even but my mom's telling myself
and my sister like he's gonna come home
today my mom was crying and my sister's
like jittery like
my sister the one I talked about before
my older sister so then
um you know we go under CCP I pop out in
courtroom I think like 50 51 55 one of
those
and it's a different it feels different
now the [__] the tank is warm like
everything changed I almost feel the
sunlight like I'm like if everything
feels happy like the judge is nice I
mean not that the judge was [__] up
before but it's different now and it's
crazy because there was this lady she
used to write me she was like like
Victory Outreach Christian lady
but she was like [__] psychic or
prophetic or some [__] she told me
you're gonna go home your next court
date
you know and and you know
I was like all right cool okay it's cool
hopefully you know like God you know
like hearing you and then there was it
was crazy because it was a satanic dude
in our dorm he was a homie it's kind of
a j cat he was cool though
you know but he was just like off but he
was like the satanic dude and and he was
in there because he had did a crime did
some robberies
and he was like I guess wanted and I
think they caught him in in the park
somewhere doing a ritual and [__] on the
floor or some some weird case it was a
weird case but he was entertainment so
I'll go [__] with that for you know talk
to him here's some here's some stories
whatever and that food told me you're
gonna go home in three court dates but
this before that lady told me that yeah
I went home on the third court date for
when he told me so whatever you know
they put me back in the tank tanks
packed this before everybody starts
going back to to you know meet himself
meet him North super max wherever their
housed at so it's the the the the the
court tank is packed you know it gets
hot in there be [__] smiling and
everybody's talking it's loud you say
wow you can't even hear [__] you know
and I go to there's a payphone in there
and I go call my boy
and then they start splitting up they
start taking you to another tank this
tank that tank
and then um
I told my I told Jay I called my boy Jay
that's it fool I signed I'll be home
tonight
[__] is on
do this [__] now because you know we've
been like like the whole time I was on
the run like I'll be on the internet all
that [__] I'll see everything telling
you when you guys were doing Fury
they've reached out to me he reached out
to my people to get at me because he had
to he had two nightmares where I was
getting chopped up in pieces and I
called the UK you guys run I called the
set while you guys were on the set so
that's what I'm saying I'll see you
shall or any of the homies that are
actors and movies are doing even though
I didn't know any of you guys but it'll
make me feel homesick because I feel
like man if I if I could be there I
could [__] with you I could [__] with
you guys you know even my boy prayers in
Kat Von D like I used to watch I used to
watch them separate and I and I just be
like man if I could just be there I know
I could [__] with these people you know
and and and
you know I'm I'm not a [__] like
scary dude I don't think it's more
intimidating nothing I feel like I'm
pretty chill and yeah and and lay back
that you know
so I'm in that tank they start splitting
people up
and then there was a dude that was in my
dorm and I had stacks of pictures Stacks
like I have fans I used to get mail from
all over the world from fans that were
just writing me I used to get mail every
day like because when you're there like
your music is already it's been out yeah
it's been I got like 60 70 albums 80
albums out so every and everybody knows
my my booking information is on the
internet so people are writing me and
you know I get I had stacks of books you
know I left probably like 500 worth of
books on my on my bunk when I left you
know because I I was what you want to
read and I just I want to read anything
like I was getting books under your cult
and religious books and this and that
and and about just like poetry and
everything and you know I would get
books just to give them away you know I
would get like like my like a easy read
that's like that I always loved was The
Alchemist yeah and and it just like
would touch my heart that and I'll read
it over and over and I want to bless
somebody with it like look this [__]
save you this is the [__] truth right
here so I'll give that book to somebody
you know and and another book that I I
read several times what I loved was um
the count of money Crystal Dumas so I
love that book you know you know he came
back got his even though he dies at the
end I don't like that part but but but
like just the whole [__] like how he was
like on some caveman [__] he goes to
that jail he gets schooled he learns all
this stuff and he comes back a new man
like with new intentions even though
they were kind of like you know spiteful
and revenge you know he wanted that
Revenge but I just love that book and
you know I would like reckon man here up
here I'll give you this you know anybody
like it if he was like cool with me then
you know and I felt like you know you're
worthy of this book and you're not just
gonna [__] like [__] hit up in
there and [__] and start
you know tagging all in and that's what
that's it so
you know so the dude in the dorm I told
him look
all my store because you know I used to
go to store on fat every day I had bags
of [__] food under my bed like which
is all bad for you which is all salt or
sugar there's like nothing I mean the
seafood has a gang of saw in it and the
sweets this was sweets I told him all my
store give it to this homie
all my books give it to this on me all
lifers all people that were fighting
life you know and then all my pictures
go to this homie and then whatever is
you know you guys split up whatever I'm
out of here to all the homies that I'm
uh you know
stay up and much love thank you for
everything you know you guys because the
homies they looked out for me in there
you know they showed a lot of love like
uh not that I got any special treatment
because I won't accept special treatment
they were kind you know and and I did
have a little
little perks and [__] you know like but
but because I was always like
straightforward and I was a team player
and I was just you know I wasn't nothing
ever went to my head I never felt like
uh you know so then the Tank's just
getting smaller and smaller smaller
smaller smaller now they changed me to
another tank it's a [__] little tank
right there in CCB it's one of those
little ones at the end of the hallway
and I'm right there now it's like
there's two dudes two Mexican dudes and
one's like hey bro your Conejo and I'm
like yeah he's like man it's my birthday
today Dawn can I get a signature a lot
of graph and I'm like yeah [__] yeah I
signed this little you know that little
pink release paper yeah I signed this
orange charge paper yeah properties yeah
sign that [__] and then they leave so
I'm like okay now it's like there's an
Asian dude who's cheat up black dude and
everything we're not no one's talking so
it's like this is the last if some
shit's gonna pop off this is it so
everybody's quiet no one's talking the
Asian dude's not talking I'm not talking
black dude's not talking everybody's
just quiet and everybody's like low-key
like checking each other out like
like because you know you never know you
know
and everybody's a g in there
everybody's a gang member in there so
everybody's just like watching each
other's moves
black do leaves they called them out now
it's me and the Asian too so we're just
like full guys long hair and she's
braided it's probably from Long Beach I
don't know I know I never I didn't ask
him you know but he's probably from
you know he's probably Cambodian that's
what I'm thinking because he's banged
out like tatted up face tattoo
everything we're just quiet
and um boom they call them out I'm in
there by myself now it's like six
o'clock Court's over I should bend out
but they had told me by you I I didn't
know that I was going to be the last guy
so I'm like man the phone doesn't work
in there it's freezing
I'm just like [__] and then finally they
call me out and they release me they
give you a little ticket like a ticket
the paper your release paper is an
actual a ticket
and I just seen this unit said 187 on it
and here's sign right here and they I
signed it and then and then now in the
county you have um
Crocs
so I got the homies Crocs I gave them
the the little fake cross trainers the
little fake Air Maxes they got in there
yeah they're cool though they look fresh
when they're brand new they're white and
crispy and um
and um
and then they you change into a paper
jumpsuit it's like black black paper
jumpsuit and the black Crocs and then
it's a it's like a garage door but it's
the big one where the buses come through
that [__] goes up
and then my sister my girl right there
wow and then I said you know I you know
I hug them
and then I'm like call my daughter
so that's the first thing I want to do I
want to talk to my daughter
so they they FaceTime me right and my
sister's like hey somebody wants to talk
to you and they put it on me like this
and she starts crying and she she's like
why you guys playing with me she thought
that I was a cardboard cutout oh she
said that why why would you guys do a
cardboard cut out on my dad why would
you guys play like that with me and
she's crying and I'm like I start
talking to her I'm like nah Mommy that's
me
Sid I just I just got out I'm out and
then we just both we just both started
crying you know like I love you Daddy I
love you Mommy and then um
went to the pad little barbecue was
waiting for me and then my girl she's
she's from Ventura so
gotta go I'm from Ventura now so yeah I
came out here and you know it just
seemed like it seemed like [__] I was
in the midwest somewhere in the middle
like I was like what the [__] like we I
remember we we got off on one exit like
we do that Santa Rosa Road that back one
when you get up the 118 to the 26th
126. yeah you get off somewhere right
there buy more park in the back and I'm
like what the [__] is this country I
just feel like that I feel like that
that when you're you know you're out of
your comfort zone that I'm like damn
like that we're gonna even have
neighbors in this how am I gonna do this
yeah what the [__] but you know and then
it just felt weird a little bit but but
then the next day I had to go to the
county and get my property
which was [__] I didn't want it I
just wanted this this is a it's called
it's from the ceremony it's a ceremony
you do for you the three-day ceremony I
didn't want nothing I just wanted my
money
and then um so I had to go see probation
they were still over there on um
Crenshaw and um
Exposition Exposition yep so I went to
go see her she was cool as [__]
went back to the county I didn't have
well I have no no ID I don't have
anything my wife had got me a birth
certificate
so I go to the county they don't want to
give me my [__] because they don't
believe that's me
and I'm telling them like but it was
enough for like the FBI and it was
enough for them to know it's me why it's
not enough for you well we need to see I
don't have an ID I've been a fugitive 15
years I don't have anything this is all
I have you know what I didn't even have
the birth certificate yet I have
anything I just had to that paper that
little sign out paper oh yeah and some
probation papers and then they gave me
my [__] back and that's it and I called
Dave no it took me like two three days
to get a cell phone
and I hit up Dave and he's on the east
coast and he's like hey I'll be back in
a week I'm gonna go pick you up all
right cool week later Dave shows up him
and [__] um what's his what's his
name um Anthony now that I know him and
Anthony came
and [__] um they pick me up go to
this Mexican restaurant
days on [__] phones you know making
deals trying to make [__] happen all
this shit's going on
and I'm like what's up and he goes oh we
got this movie
I'm like all right cool he's all you're
gonna be in it I'm like all right cool
what's my I told him I'm right told him
what's my name gonna be in the movie
he's like and I'm like oh [__] cool but
I already have been telling Dave like
about the afro-cuban religions about
like intricate workings of the way the
things that I've seen you know that
could help them in the script you know
so they kind of injected that into a tax
collector and he was just like here go
see [__] what's her name um
what's the name of um
Ivana chubbock yeah yeah go see her show
up at this address we're gonna be
[__] rehearsing for a few months
come here every day and that's it did
you did you enjoy it did all that [__]
would you like it yeah I did yeah and I
remember um we were rehearsing right
at first
it was just me
and Bobby me Bobby and Cynthia and as
time went on like another cast member
came on which was that uh what's her
name Chelsea
but I remember the day Shia walked in
you know it's kind of StarStruck a
little bit not Starstruck like because
you know but but he walked in and he was
bald just for his head it was shaved and
then he had some Levi's and the way they
were folded he that's how skinheads do
it so I'm like this was supposed to be
on a [__] skinhead movie or some [__]
that's what I thought and he walked in
like Shia you know he's him you know and
he looked at me he's like ah
heard about you whatever yeah and what
up bro we shook hands and then they
started running the scene when they're
driving in the car him and Bobby and I
was just like damn I was kind of
intimidated by them because like these
[__] are real actors I don't
know what the [__] I'm doing you know
like I just better shut the [__] up in
peep game and soak it up as much as I
can you know because I know Dave's gonna
call on me right now and tell me to say
something or something I'm gonna be like
ah and I gotta like and then you know
more people started before not and then
the rehearsals started getting bigger
bigger bigger and then I remember one
day um I see George Lopez walking and I
was kind of the same like Shia like kind
of StarStruck I'm like man this
[__] is bigger than that then he
looks you know he looks fake to me you
know [__] little black tuxedo and
[__] I'm like honest who's looking
spiffy and [__] he walked in and that
fool told me the same [__] he shaked
everybody he knew I think everybody he's
like
like [__] you you kill me in the movie
or some [__] and then he just shook my
hand he was cool and then I said and
from there like just everything you know
what like all these things started
happening and you know and then so you
know Bobby I got close with him and and
and there was a lot of ties you know
because Bobby's you know his family and
his grandpa and the area and then Dave
he was like [__] West Adams was like
running [__] like we were in the [__]
building like it felt good you know but
it feel like like good like even though
I didn't I don't know I I known about
Bobby for years I just never met him I
know about him I know his whole [__]
but
everything that happens for a reason and
and and everything happens at the right
place at the right time so my story is a
story of perseverance and and even
though I like I feel like giving up a
hundred times but I kept that [__] going
and that's why I went like
dude's like step to me and they're like
hey I'm like man [__] out of here with
that [__] like man I had all kinds of
adversity I kept it going and and I had
all the I went against the odds and and
so there's no excuse you know it's hard
to accept excuses from people that got
the sad stories right yeah like hey hook
me up I'm the [__] I'm like exactly man
everybody's a [__] everybody is a [__]
but just you know you gotta like I don't
know grind you gotta grind and and and
just you know work hard and I like I
made it I'm just I'm I'm out here just
like
but I'm enjoying the journey you know
it's cool you know acting I think is
cool because it's it's not like the
music it will it's sort of like the
music it's still on Art you know when I
could tell like different [__] you know
and I could show them like
you know I got a lot of life experience
in a lot of different areas that that
probably a lot of people don't have you
know so man it's been a pleasure yeah
man I swear man oh yup thank you bro
yeah I just appreciate you being so open
man and sharing everything with us and
that [__] was kind of painful the whole
way through it you know no I had good I
had good times like I said life is life
and I had
beautiful times over there and I feel
like
like as far as the music that's where I
found my voice
over there because
you know I just had so much content so
much [__] to talk about and all the [__]
that was going on and I miss home so
much and
you know I found my voice over there and
and a lot of things you know
I didn't believe in I mean I believed in
God but I am believing him like I
believe in him now you know the guys my
ancestors you know all these things and
whatever you know I didn't I wasn't
[__] reading [__] over here over that
I read I like close to 300 bucks it took
me to lose my firstborn son Dante Jr and
and 15 years in the federal pen before I
picked up a Bible and really try to get
an understanding man so you know
everybody got that moment man but I
think the most important thing here is
you know the change you've made through
all that you know you know look what you
went through and look what you are you
know and I think that's the most
important part I think that's what I
want people to get out of your story man
that it ain't no excuses you know I
think it's it's very important that you
share that man I appreciate you coming
man we appreciate you man thank you
thank you that was an honor yeah
oh [__]
[Music]